thank you so much rich really appreciate
the the introduction there and as the
name of the panel implies we're going to
talk a little bit about how hiring
getting hired finding a job is changing
today and Mark is a great person to tell
us about this because he's been in the
industry for a pretty long time so with
that mark I'd actually love for you to
start and tell us a little bit about the
ladders and how you decided to start it
with the thesis behind the company was
sort of to begin with sure would love to
and thanks for inviting me to be here
first off i love that we're at a tech
conference and it's a yale conference
that's only to yell tech conference that
the majority of speakers on stage before
noon or women so here's to us that's
that's pretty exciting and so started
the ladders 12 years ago I had been as
SVP at hot jobs hochhaus at the number
two job board behind a monster it had
been founded in 98 I joined after when
public got a lot of exposure to
different parts of the business Yahoo
came and bought us and they did what
Yahoo did with has done with all the
requisitions over time it took us from a
strong number two to a distant number
five in the space of about five years
and at the time the boss there were
3,000 employees which is relatively
small but that's just seemed huge to me
so I didn't want to go work there and so
I took took time off and then ended up
really wanted to do something else in
online recruitment and I was either
going to do something for hourly or for
like the very high end and it just
struck me that people didn't at that
point understand really how to use the
internet or how to use it to achieve
goals outside a very narrow technical
goals so I had a couple of cousins in
town who who were from a big Irish
Italian Catholic family I've got 36
first cousins so they would they'd call
me and say hey mr. hotjobs how do i how
do I find my next job it's like it's
easy just go online you search and you
see what the shop so I don't know how to
do that can you do that for me so I go
I'd search I'd put them in an email send
them off to a mite great that's
so fantastic Wow next week they call me
back he can do it again so yeah sure cuz
I throw for you in the search set it off
to him next week they call that can do
it again and then like you know my six
years of higher education and expensive
you know business school education kick
in and I say wow here is an unmet need
and so the idea was will take all the
great jobs out there at the time it was
only hundred k plus today it's all
professional jobs put them in the email
newsletter and send it out to people
every week charge them 25 bucks a month
or ninety nine dollars a year for the
for the service and so started that in
my East Village apartment 12 years ago
Wow and so the thesis it sounds like at
the time was people don't know how to
use the internet let's compile an
easy-to-read newsletter with jobs that
fit their needs and criteria people now
our internet savvy but can you tell us a
little bit more about other factors that
you've seen change in the world of work
what has changed in the way that people
are trying to find jobs from hot jobs
all the way until today so what hasn't
changed that people still don't know how
to market themselves well for everybody
in the room when you've been through a
job search and you had to put together
your resume was there a feeling of joy
and glee in your in your in your heart
or was there a little bit of anxiety in
the pit of your stomach general people
find a bit of anxiety I how do I explain
myself there's so much so much to tell
there's so little space I can only make
the margins so wide and the so I think
the central idea is that people still
need help marketing themselves just as
businesses need help marking themselves
and small businesses need to help
marketing themselves I think as we get
more you know more and more
sophisticated as professionals and as a
professionals who have to manage our own
careers but that's become more and more
important so the understanding the
internet part of it has gotten yet
people are you know living on there you
know amazing supercomputers that they
carry around in their pockets all day
totally living on I totally get that but
they still don't quite know how to how
to market themselves in a way that is
effective yeah and so part of marketing
yourself is picking how
you're going to access a particular job
and job boards were the traditional way
to do that you would see a job you would
apply through a job in my experience at
higher art we get upward of 500 resumes
a week when we post a job to a site like
Craigslist is that still an effective
way to submit an application is it
effective for the candidate and honestly
is it effective for the employer to
receive applications that way so the the
surprising thing so that when i started
at hot jobs we still sometimes had the
case where sales people had to go out to
a client get under their desk and plug
the phone jack into a modem so they
could login / AOL dial-up to search the
system 10 years ago even in 2005 you
said hey HR is actually going to go
through a technology revolution over the
next 10 years and adopt everything that
the tech HR industry has to sell it not
just part of it but just everything
whole-hog they're going to a crazy for
it you simply won't have believed it
because HR had resisted for 50 years
mainframe computing and a lot of
automation that was routine in other
parts of the the business I think it's
the latest generation coming into the
workforce it was brick a BYOD bring your
own device bring your own network as
Millennials came in with their iphones
or came in with their Facebook or
Twitter accounts kind of already up in
part of how they communicated it it just
caused all resistance in HR to crumble
and so the the field of how people are
thinking about how can technology make
us better at hiring today is is it can't
possibly it's a different country
different planet to where it was 10
years ago and so within that HR
departments and hiring managers are way
more innovative in terms of what they'll
do it's not just you know as Henry
Blocher is saying at first what people
try to do is they just try to take the
old media and kind of force it into the
new media and so at first we just try to
take job listings from the newspaper and
enforce it into the online frame now you
see a lot more innovative
stuff with how people can act now people
network and whether it's higher art or
job bite or a whole host of other things
yeah so I want to agree and I want to
disagree with you actually so that I
agreed that HR is going through a
massive revolution and I hope it happens
having said that when you look at where
people are still applying for jobs the
statistics actually haven't changed in
about 15 years about a third of them
apply through job boards about a third
of them apply through contingency and
other types of recruiters and about a
third of them come in through referrals
from other people in the company other
kinds of tools are still a very tiny
fraction of the market why do you think
that's happening is HR actually going
through a revolution or are we just
thinking that it is because we're in
revolutionary companies sure so so job
listings have changed it's a way way
different from where it was 15 years ago
and sometimes what we credit to job
listings is if you've posted an
opportunity on Stack Exchange where the
world's software engineers hang out yes
it's a job listing but it's in a very
very particular market and there's a
very very particular type of follow-up
that that goes on there it's if that's
still jobless thing then yes you're
correct but it just it's so different
from what it was in the newspaper and in
terms of the kind of that rough
breakdown between a third let's call it
the third is like random advertising
yeah yeah I'm going to we call it post
and pray right people post their job out
there they hope what is going to happen
a third is from people that your
employees already know and a third is
from paid agents of your company to go
out there and get stuff as I've read
back in the history that's 200 years ago
that was also how companies were finding
employees about in that about in that in
that mix I don't think that fundamental
human behavior is going to change but
what's enabling it whether it's hey I
found this guy guy on Twitter who's
who's tweeting a lot about database
marketing why don't we bring a mat or
hey we need somebody to who has a
certain zest to represent our brand we
found them on Instagram or hey we need
somebody a very very specialized area we
found like the one person in North
Dakota who does us on linkedin those are
totally new ways to do what is the other
classic human behavior
yeah yeah no it's interesting that you
mention it because in some ways I think
the Internet has given us a chance to
exacerbate our worst behaviour so for
instance craigslist has been around for
a long time but recently I heard about a
startup that allows you to auto submit
you every to every single job on
Craigslist without having to do anything
else so here you are you can just spam
everybody that you that you can and in
some ways I think that's that's
something that other tools are trying to
stop and one thing you mentioned that i
think is quite interesting is the idea
of different skills that are coming up
so instagram allows you to see
somebody's graphic design skills or
somebody photography skills on linkedin
you can find somebody very niche tell us
a little bit about how the skills have
changed from 2003 when you were starting
the ladders all the way through now what
are employers looking for in candidates
today that they perhaps Warren at the
time you mean overall the the wave of
Millennials coming into the workplace
has been a has been a big impact on
industry if you work with Millennials
nod your head all right uh you've
experienced this and it's bet you know
it's been an adjustment period for
everybody when Millennials first kind of
showed up am I at the Landers ten years
ago it was all the classic stuff boy
they seemed really entitled and they
want to get you know promoted white
right away and they want raises all the
time and yeah they want feedback but
they want positive warm nurturing
feedback it's preferably are you giving
me anybody Beckett I think you look
wonderful and it's other questions have
already been fantastic and so this is uh
I needed that halfway through right
there good and so we fight so we were
kind of Gen Xers and boomers that at
that point we fought it you know they
look it's a you come in it's a
entry-level program it's two years till
you get promoted put your nose down and
I go do it and yeah we we probably you
know browbeat the new recruits into
submission but there's other new
recruits every six months and so finally
we're like well look we this is just not
going to change and so we decided to
change our program so we broke up the
two 12 year promotion in 26 promotions
over two years instead of coming in at
as associate and game promoted to senior
associate you start
off as a junior analyst than four months
later rose and less than you know
performance laterz senior analyst then
junior associate associate senior
associate the pay rate at the end was
the same and you know the world laughing
but the fantastic thing is that it
worked for everybody right it really
worked for everybody we got at the end
of two years we had people kind of at
the point that they're supposed to be in
at the Patriot they're supposed to be
and for the Millennials it was hey you
know I got the feedback i wanted i got
the call mom and dad like dad you know
cheers i got a beer I got a promotion at
work at work today and you know thinking
about that there's some interesting
stepping in san fran generation stuff
there's some interesting business
insight there which is look we all yet
the psychological research is pretty
clear that positive feedback more more
often works than not now the negative
feedback in certain cases can be helpful
but mostly it's positive feedback
rewarding people for the behaviors that
you're looking for is the way to get
what youre the behaviors that you want
out of them so this generation wants
more positive feedback hey that's
terrific hey they're very
achievement-oriented and they're looking
for what do I have to do quickly to get
through this hoop well that's kind of a
smart business goal isn't it and they
want the feedback loop to be swayed much
much smaller than traditionally which in
any if any of your engineers are in be
working a type of physical manufacturing
you know that the quicker your feedback
loop is the faster you can actually
improve things and get your your
production process better so overall I
kind of came around for the position
from originally you know what a bunch of
entitled people coming into my company
to realizing that at the end of it it
was we were actually far better off with
the new system than we were with the
with the old system and so I think the
biggest changes have been this brick
this attitude brought to modern business
are probably the biggest biggest changes
I've seen in the decade yeah yeah this
every year of the generation you know
what's your what's your view well one
thesis I have is that the skills that
are required for work have changed
drastically over the last last couple of
years the expectation that I have for
anyone who joins higher art now is a
very high level of intellect around
and internet usage and so just being
able to use the internet in a normal way
is not enough understanding how code
works how HTML works having basic
understanding of things like sequel
almost for any job even our customer
service person now has to be able to run
very basic queries in order to help
people that's changed a lot and and so
one thing I think about is our colleges
preparing people well enough for these
for these kinds of jobs at technology
companies and and beyond just
engineering which isn't often talked
about topic we all know there's not
enough computer scientists but do you
think that universities are giving
people the right set of skills whether
it's behavioral or actual skills that's
that's the that's really a trade-off
that we face particularly coming out of
Yale the a liberal education they
weren't there weren't courses in
accounting on purpose there weren't
courses in marketing on purpose there
weren't a lot of courses in business on
purpose so my senior year I mean
literally decide what it's going to do
because I you know I read in New York
Times business section that
international trade might be big in the
next decade and that's okay I'm going to
go into that and there are there minuses
to that system and there are there plus
to that system how vocational do we want
our college education to be over a
college education to be overall in our
society but then particularly you know
with with in Yale how vocational you
want to get and I think the I think the
answer is probably not to vocation it's
it's far better to have you know kind of
the insight from having read literature
and read deeply in history to understand
kind of the influences behind people's
behavior and why they think what they
what they think it would they do what
they do rather than you know my sequel
yesterday or postgres sequel today or no
sequel tomorrow because those will fade
away it's interesting that you say that
almost every job today is you know
technology enabled one of the things so
I right what we're pretty sure as
America's largest career advice
newsletter goes out to eight million
people every monday morning at the
ladders we think its largest in the
world there might be some place in China
or Brazil it's that's larger and one of
the probably the most intractable
problem that comes up is age
discrimination
and I didn't really know when I got into
the field 15 years ago the age
discrimination was such a such a serious
thing but it is and and it and the age
at which the discrimination starts you
know keeps dropping so now like in
certain tech industries if you know late
30s early 40s is time for your
colleagues to it's a fact your
colleagues going to start wondering
about you I think in business in general
you you see that even in old line
industries by 50 52 people have
questions about unfair questions about
your capabilities do you think this is a
particular phenomenon that's happening
in Silicon Valley or in Silicon Alley
with companies started by people in
their 20s or is it is it soon amin on
that is a cross across it's a phenomenon
that's result from the breakdown of
lifetime employment so until nineteen
ninety three IBM your if you get job IBM
you're there for life februari of 1990 3
y-b emesis for the first time we're
going to have layoffs and that just kind
of started for the whole country and so
now instead of me one company managing
your career moving you through a whole
bunch of different postings you are
supposed to manage your career and run
yourself through a whole bunch of
different postings and I think the most
in sort of company ultimately I've come
to you on that is that age set
discrimination isn't so much age
discrimination is it so much age
discrimination as it is mindset
discrimination I've met or perceived
mindset discrimination I would say well
I've meant 60 year olds who you know are
in who is he a stick about new
technology and what's going on on
Instagram but not like in a weird I'm
trying to be a teenager way but just
like interested in it and and engage
with it that don't have a problem at all
and I've met you know thirtysomethings
who are very sitting there ways and
don't wanna learn the new thing and
Microsoft Excel is good enough for you
know for my dad so I think good for good
enough for you and I think more and more
this mindset of I didn't just learn one
thing in college and I'm going to apply
for the next 40 years but every year
there's going to be some new thing and
I've got to adapt as I go along whether
you're just out of school and starting
at higher art or whether you're you know
that several decades into your career
that mindset is the most important right
so it's interesting one thing you're
bringing up here is what colleges should
teach you is to learn how to learn
because it seems like every two years
skills we require from a technical
standpoint are going to change so being
able to to adapt your skill set seems
important I absolutely so what one thing
that I've noticed though is that the
jobs that are being created by
technology companies happens art of on
two extremes either you're going to be a
very creative person you're going to
come up with new ideas new marketing
campaigns that are changing everything
or you're going to be working for
instacart as a delivery person or or 11
delivering things or for ebay couriers
or you know higher art hires a lot of
people for Google self-driving car
testers one of the most popular job on
our site hundreds of self-driving car
texture people who are testing it seems
like a bit of a all graduated from like
Santa Clara University or Berkeley or
somewhere like that and if it sounds
like an easy job you know it's actually
probably not that easy because you have
to be so much the tension oh it's like
they're good i guess that's right as
long as it currently you know but it's
not a very intellectually rigorous job
neither is being a delivery person for
ebay now or google shopping or hundreds
of these jobs that are being created so
do you think that the tech world is
creating interesting jobs for people or
is it automating on the other hand at
the thing you haven't talked about the
obvious big elephant in the room around
technology is our jobs being automated
away that previously were actually good
professions for people to have when I go
to the bank today I don't ask the bank
teller for help I just use the ATM when
I get to the airport I don't need
anybody to help me check in i just
checked myself in if I already didn't do
that on my cell phone so how are people
getting jobs given this bifurcation of
career opportunities right yeah look the
guy who invented the wheel probably got
you know rag Don for putting the people
who used to carry stuff out of work
right so you know every time we have new
technology people bring this up and say
hey that's good you're going to throw
the people that we're doing the thing
that's being automated out of work it's
a conventional wisdom of viewpoint
anytime you actually look at the data
across first off across society and
across most people it's a benefit and
then there but there are inevitably
cases where somebody's been in a field
20 25 30 years it gets a
I made it away and then they're really
stuck and their life outcome is you know
dramatically dramatically reduced but in
aggregate new technology and better
productivity in anything is best for all
of us so whether it's information being
processed more quickly or cars being put
together more quickly by by robots or
digits being dug faster whatever it is
technology is a positive enabler and
eight unbelievably positive force in our
world and I see your point I mean there
are probably discussions like this
happening during the industrial
revolution where people are saying hey
we're all getting fired from our jobs
because they're taken up being taken
over by machines and that's that's a
fair point but it seems like this
revolution is happening so quickly and
and so many jobs are being destroyed
that a bunch of people are getting left
behind and the question is can those
folks learn the new skills that are
required to participate in the new
economy one of my favorite stories is so
hire art what we do is we allow people
to showcase their skills in order to get
a job and one of our clients was a
company in the bay area that was hiring
an excel and sequel analyst and a person
and it could be anywhere the person
could be anywhere and a person from
Detroit who had been working at Barnes &
Noble or some book store apply for the
job and said hey I've been teaching
myself how to use excel using online
free courses for the last two years and
she was actually one of the finalists
she didn't get hired but she was on the
finalists and it was this awe-inspiring
story for me of somebody who was able to
transform their skill set but is that a
common story and is that an expectation
that we should have for the barnes and
noble cashier to become competitive
against people in the Bay Area on a
sequel job so the truth of the matter is
today that the education system
particularly for our most disadvantaged
citizens is horrible and preparing them
for the future it's not just a pity but
it's a shame and there's so much that
should be done to fix it progress isn't
going to stop while we wait for that to
be fixed even if you wanted to
if you wanted to say that's keep all the
ATM its key to forget the atms let's
keep the tellers that's keep the
cashiers lets you know keep them higher
paying jobs you can wish for that just
consumers are going to go and do the
thing that's more efficient and frankly
you know I don't wish for that because I
think that if we can replace those jobs
with jobs that require people to express
their creativity their intellect etc
that's much better for everyone involved
but but it's I think a hard transition
now we only have a couple minutes left
and one topic I want to talk to you a
little bit about is career advice for
for folks in the audience recent Yale
graduates or people who've been out of
school a couple of years tell me a
little bit about sort of the career arcs
that you see Yale graduates have and
what advice you might have about
mistakes people make either in picking
jobs or in in kind of formulating their
stories around around their careers yeah
I don't know if anybody's qualified to
give anybody else career advice but I
can tell you what I've what I've
observed what the is probably the most
common error that I see and people
coming to me for career advice to kind
of in aggregate cost millions of people
is that they just don't do what they
think is going to make them happy and
there are all sorts of reasons why they
come up for it with why doing this other
thing is what they ought to do one of my
you know one of my newsletters uh that
it up getting some traction it was
titled the boy who filed someone else's
dream and I had a friend of a friend
come in an interview for a finance
director job at the ladders and I'll
just won't use her name while just ad
and Saudi said to me well look I really
want this job as finance director of
ladders I'm explained it to me and you
have to put 10 minutes like di don't buy
it I don't believe you yeah you're
qualified you work your Harvard Business
School your JPMorgan Chase all its near
terrific background I don't buy that you
actually want this job or that you
actually even interested in finance
because you just don't strike me as
somebody who's telling me the truth and
being authentic when you're on the go
fast to look yet when you're after you
put the two kids to bed at night and
you're at home and you're just by
yourself you kind of have a moment what
is it that you kind of dream about all
right her eyes light up she says for
sure she says food
I love food I love food blogging I like
I'm like what's your food blog she's
like this I look up and she's got like
all this amazing food blog stuff out
there I am just I'm terrific i'm so
excited about it I said watch it watch
go do that like seems like you like it
won't you go do that say well my parents
and classmates from HBS don't think it's
very prestigious as I you know when when
have great success has ever occurred by
following what other people's advice was
like there's no book titled the boy who
followed someone else's dream right
that's not that's not the book that you
read to your kids in the bed at night
and I did the follow-up news out of the
polyp news that are so she didn't go the
back to the banking or finance path she
took a job at a famous fast service food
place here in New York for a couple
years now she's a senior person at a
famous home delivery of faith fresh
direct and as she terrific and like
she's doing food and she loves it and
whatever I can't tell you how many times
that's like if there's like what's the
core problem somebody's job search that
they know in their heart of hearts
what's going to make them happy and they
they have come up with some reason why
that's what they're not going to do I
had another another guy who's out in the
Midwest who you want to be ahead of a
division in a two to 10 billion dollar
food district distribution company and
somehow he got into his head that what
was cool was the smaller faster growing
things and so each week when it got on
the phone with them he would tell me
yeah yeah we'll tell me about your
pipeline what are you interviewing for
it was all like 22 509 smaller food
distribution businesses and be like well
a you told me that what you really want
to do is be in this larger company
because you got invited more
infrastructure and you can do more
interesting things that's really
fascinating to you what why is
everything in your pipeline these
smaller companies well that's whatever
he's talking about these days and that's
what's that's what's cool and honestly
like two months of my working with them
was like breaking him out of doing what
somebody else's dream was and just being
answered himself about this is what I
like one of the tough things
particularly for for bright folks to
realize is that your life up until the
point you graduate Yale has been about
doors my last semester yeah i kinda I
took a course intro course to
architecture I had no business taking
intro course to architecture but it's
been fantastic last 20 years i have i
have a barely formed opinion on
architecture but that I enjoy as I go
around it we had more time I'd love to
drill drill into but stuff no it's
barely form it has no business being on
stage but it was enjoyable and terrific
and and so your life up to graduated
Yale is about opening doors your life
honestly after yells about closing doors
and particularly i was going to hear
that they get maybe a little bit bummed
out maybe we all do like wow that sounds
bummer like restaurant live closer goes
but it's not actually that inspiring now
but it's actually true like I mean to
think about if you're on some music
service you're on Spotify at first you
kind of go around you listen to
everything and yes you know nepalese
throat singing is awesome and the stuff
that you find from they kind of you know
world music from Cuba and like the
django reinhardt stuff from the 1930s is
amazing but over time you realize you
know that's not really what I want to
listen to it what I really want to
listen to is this and you close the
doors on like the the music that you
don't like and if I sit there and say
well isn't that sad that you stopped
listening to music when you don't like
it's a no I I'm spending my time listen
to music I do like and your career after
you graduate Yale is learning about
things that you know exist hey do I want
to do sales it turns out i really don't
what i want to do is marketing or hey do
you want to do marketing no i don't like
doing that kind of stuff i want to do
database programming or do you like
database program you know I prefer
finance and accounting closing the doors
is really what your career is about for
the like the next 40 to 50 years and the
sooner you realize that just because
somebody else went through that door
doesn't mean that you go through that
door just because your mother father
siblings friends classmates peers
celebrity that you look up to says that
yogurt that door doesn't mean you go
through that door you gotta figure out
what you actually like what is it unspun
to phi that you actually like and listen
to that what is it your career that you
actually enjoy doing you get some thrill
or passion out of and then they do the
most courageous thing possible which is
go do that whatever the obstacles are
whatever the the hurdles are go do that
I love that message i think that's
that's so true it's one of the things we
find on higher art is exactly
same thing either people are applying
for jobs that they actually don't want
or they're unable to articulate what
they what they do want so one of the
other pieces is giving yourself time
yeah to figure out what it is you want I
mean the food story is great but not all
of us have something that you're like so
passionate about off the bat so I think
figuring out what that but that's
bravery that's what brave bravery isn't
knocking down everything else out there
and kind of being snarky and you know
supercilious about stuff bravery is like
putting yourself out there and being
authentic and like trying things and
learning about whether or not I I like
it regardless of whether something is
laughing at me or whatever is something
is stupid that's what bravery is Raines
that's that'd be my advice for folks so
I love that message and I want to end on
that for this particular part of the
talk we have a two or three minutes left
for questions if anyone has any
questions they'd like to ask top three
piece of advice you would give to a
student as far as their online presence
of LinkedIn to get a job well the top
three bits bits of advice uh so
everybody in the room probably has a
linkedin profile so I'm not really
groundbreaking there with that it would
be get your message figure out what your
message is what is somebody going to
hype so a hiring manager who has a job
what are they going to hire you for it
is it is three things they're going to
hear for they're gonna hire you to
increase sales or to do marketing
whatever figure out what that message is
and then repeat that message in every
bit of your online profile whatever it
is so if you're a logistics person in
Minneapolis you're going to probably be
working at Target or Dayton or something
like that your focus is I love logistics
here's the part of logistics on good
aunt here are the innovative new things
that I'm doing logistics right and
repeat that over and over and over again
don't say that you can also do you know
I'm also interested in marketing I'm
also interested in you know
international travel I sometimes I think
about internet you know franchising in
the southwestern United States because
people really only spend six to eight
seconds looking at your online profiles
before they figure out whether you go
into the next pile or not make it easy
for them by telling them here's what I
want to do any other one final question
all right well with that thank you so
much more for your time thanks so much